The joe rogan experience,
you can actually beat him if you're
going to push it all the,
what is it in your brain that makes you
do that?
Cause like we just looked at your mvps
that you burned a thousand calories.
Is there some sort of,
I talked to Pat McAfee one time,
he said it's about exclusivity.
It's about rape and murder.
It's my head's filled with it.
Stopping rapists and stop and murderers
and killing child molesters.
That's what I think about killing bad
people when you work out.
Yeah.
That's what I do when I get tired.
If I get tired,
I think about like saving someone I care
about.
I think about stopping someone who's
trying to murder someone I love.
That's what I think about.
I love your face.
I'm not kidding.
I think about my second wife.
I think about protecting people I care
about.
Then you tell,
you told me one time,
um,
if it's hard,
you'll go a pretending someone is trying
to kill me.
Yeah.
So you're like pretending.
I really don't have words for that.
That's what you gotta do.
Cause that's,
that's what if you think about worst
case scenario,
you're tired and someone's trying to
kill someone you care about and you
don't have enough energy to stop them.
But do you think you learned that switch
in like a tie?
Tuck one or not taekwondo?
Uh,
uh,
yeah,
I learned it from martial arts for sure.
Yeah.
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
Yeah,
because that's the scariest place you
could ever be.
Like the scariest place you could be is
life and death.
So like it just putting yourself in
Olin,
just want to lose weight.
Okay,
good.
Yeah,
that's good.
Well,
but that's not,
you're not going to save yourself like
you gotta you gotta put yourself in like
animalistic fury.
That's how you get,
you got to put yourself,
you got to put yourself in this,
this state of just 100% effort.
Yeah.
I was pegged at like 180 177 beats per
minute for the last 35 35 minutes.
That's really right.
It's got to do it.
See the,
you know that David Goggins guy had
gotten my head with a just embrace the
suck.
Yeah,
I can,
I can get there where I go and just pray
like,
like doing the marathon.
I just go,
this is where I'm going be in for the
next five and half hours.
This is where I'm at and this what I'm
doing and I can,
I can wrap my head around that.
I don't know if I can wrap my head
around like I don't know the explicit
severity of it and going like,
I'm going to save my family and then
getting,
but that might not work for you,
but there still could be a different
tactic that works for you.
You know what I mean?
Like even like bat going that fucking
hard to where your body is completely
giving out.
There's part of me that goes,
hey man,
what are we doing here?
You know,
like when I'm working out I go,
that's really fucking hard.
Well you got,
you definitely have to protect your
health,
right?
Like the last you want to be doing this
and having a heart attack.
That's my,
that's always my fear is I go easy
buddy.
Easy buddy is a good way to look at it.
But I've been doing that kind of working
out forever.
That's how I work out.
Yeah,
that's,
you always were crazy.
Yeah,
I go crazy.
Did you ever think of,
have you ever thought about who like
really
disrespected you right before you lift?
You know what I mean?
Like right before us.
And that's all that happens online.
You can't read that shit
ever.
I've gone to like a moment where you're
like,
I wish I would have cracked that dude in
the face.
And then right before,
right before I said no,
I have not been.
I know I'm definitely know what I want.
I know who I'm thinking about and I'm
gonna try it.
All right.
Don't say any names.
What does he rhyme with?
[inaudible]
you guys are doing or you guys can do a
benefit,
a comedy benefit?
I would do anything.
I'll help out however I can,
but he doesn't need come on my show to
do.
If he's thinking I went here for three
hours,
I'll do whatever you want.
What?
Same like make sure I don't forget his
name.
It seemed like I was on the plane the
other day,
man.
And this,
um,
I don't want mess up his name and be a
dickhead.
And uh,
Oh,
Ray Borg.
I've seen Ray Borg son,
no sick babies having these surgeries.
And I saw someone post a shirt,
that ray board,
uh,
go to Ray Borg,
instagram or twitter and he puts his
shirt,
he goes,
all these profe the proceeds from the
shirt go to help me pay for my child's
medical bill.
And so a song,
go shop,
look into this.
And so I clicked on it and I see it.
You don't have a two and a half ago.
It's son.
I see his son on the,
the like the,
the frickin respirator broke my heart.
So I dm Tim and Ray,
I,
I'm sure bunch of people hit you up,
man.
There it is.
Idm Gray because we need help with the
medical bills.
I will pay for your medical bills,
right?
I will cover it man.
So when I,
when I say here,
I get emotional because I see a son.
When I say I'll help you re I'm dead
serious man.
I'm not one of these guys who just,
I don't need the publicity.
I don't need any of that.
I sent you my idmg by number.
I will cover the medical bills,
man.
I got you brother.
I got you,
man.
Hit me up.
It's not a game.
It's no publicity.
I will take care of you.
You and your family.
That's it.
Well look,
here you go.
Emotional dude.
When I see his kid on there,
man,
fucking kill you.
I know,
I know.
Just took me by surprise.
Sorry Dude.
I'm good now.
Do you know ray?
I don't know man.
I'll never met him.
Wow.
Never met him.
So how much money does he need to raise?
I don't know,
but I'm fucking rich.
I'm doing a show in Utah.
Donate all the money I make from my six
shows.
And you told his medical bills.
Beautiful.
That's beautiful man.
Wiseguys St Louis.
October,
I think 10th through the 12th I'm doing
for her.
I think it's six shows.
I'll take all that money.
You can have it right.
That was beautiful.
That's a beautiful place to great place,
man.
Yeah.
Love,
Love Utah.
Does it?
Does he not have medical insurance?
I don't know.
I don't think it covers it.
And He,
you know,
he's a broke fighter.
Yeah.
He's a broke fighter man.
And I just,
dude,
I'm so fortunate,
like me finding standup and I get so
much cool stuff in the works and this
Bravo's show,
I'm like,
dude,
you just can't take,
take,
take.
Yeah.
You know,
I give them my family and all that.
I'm like,
after we have to figure something out
here,
that's when I saw that I'm like,
what the fuck man,
that's awesome man.
They think that it's because of the
singular
aspect of their diet and the fact that
they've eliminated everything else,
but they're not,
they don't do any studying of
elimination diets.
They don't do any study of the prolonged
benefits of fasting and all these
different things that you're talking
about,
which I think are v there.
These are all factors in this really
complicated thing that's going on that
most likely has something to do with
their gut biome and their immune system.
Right?
Absolutely.
I mean,
those are two major confounding factors
was like so major,
you know,
it's,
um,
it's important.
It's just important to approach this
like a science,
you know,
and,
and not like a religion,
like you said,
where are you want to believe something.
And so you just find,
you know,
this,
this study that I also see circulating
lot around that why plants are really
bad to eat.
It's like they're there,
they're there means that the insect anti
nutrients or pesticides or my former
mentor.
Okay.
Dr. Bruce Ames who spent his entire
career like advocating micro nutrients
from vegetables and from me and from
fish.
Okay.
It's like so ironic,
but if you actually read the paper,
not only does it say it doesn't,
you know,
these,
these insect anti feed ins like
sulforaphane don't cause cancer,
but it also goes,
has a whole section on Heterocyclic
aimings from cooked meat.
So if you really want to use that paper
as an argument,
why to not eat plants,
then maybe read the paper and realize,
oh,
it's also talking about Heterocyclic
aimings as well.
The point of the paper was like,
I'm getting a little motion him.
I'm sorry sir.
I'm sorry.
I like it.
Um,
the getting out of your robot.
The point of the paper was basically not
to worry about like some of the amounts
that you're being exposed to you with
some of these natural,
you know,
ants in sec anti feed that are found in
plants and some of the cook things and
meet and as well as some of the
pesticides that are found in synthetic
pesticides because it basically that
they're in such small amounts that,
so that was kind of the point of the
paper was back in the 90s.
Um,
and,
but I just think that it's a little,
I don't know how hypocritical to use a
paper,
you know,
as a,
as like,
and literally it's like,
I mean it's like proliferate it
everywhere.
That's a pic,
this paper all the time.
It's like,
well,
did you read the paper?
Because it has a whole section on um,
on the insect antipodes from coffee,
which a lot of people drink.
And also for me,
like that didn't stick.
But then some of them do stay,
you can't say retarded anymore.
That one sticking.
Right.
Like and people are realizing there's
certain things that you can do and
certain things you can't do.
Certain things.
We accept certain things we can't accept
anymore and we're figuring it out and
we're figuring it out in real time,
in a,
at a radical pace that's never existed
before in human history where something
that was acceptable just 10 15 years ago
is completely unacceptable now that's,
there's never been a time like that
before.
Never been a time in the entire world
since people started talking.
There's never been a time where change
is taking place at such a radical pace,
and you're a part of it and I'm a part
of it and everyone is to,
this is a part of it.
We're all together in this and no one
knows where the fuck it's going.
Okay.
I love that you're,
you're saying that the reason all this
is happening right now is because we are
now,
we're just communicating at a more rapid
pace.
That's all it boils down to.
You're absolutely right.
It's the communication revolution.
Yeah.
And if so,
if someone says,
you know,
well,
hey you,
you,
you said it doesn't make sense.
Like,
yeah,
for sure.
Well,
no one's going to get it right.
No one's going to get it right all the
time.
Like no one does.
No,
I'm,
I'm not an oracle.
My fucking human.
I was born in New Jersey.
No,
it's no getting this right.
Being held to that standard oil.
We all are now
what's be,
there's good to that too.
Okay.
The good is you realize like what you're
responsible,
like if you make a mistake and what,
or you say something incorrect or you
say something mean they were just trying
to be funny to came out bad,
but the,
the,
the blow back,
let's,
you know,
this is how people feel about that and
it's a disproportionate,
because your signals disproportionate do
your ability to express yourself as
disproportionate.
Yeah.
So the blow back is going to be
disproportionate as well,
so it feels awful.
But that's just,
uh,
an affirmation.
Just letting you know.
Okay.
No,
the fake ass as an audience,
you got to just keep the spectacle alive
almost.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
If it's not a spectacle,
it's not interesting.
I guess I have to keep changing things.
If it's not an absolute spectacle to the
vision,
your,
your brain will catch onto the the my
favorite word.
Fuckery.
Yeah.
I love that word too.
It's my favorite word.
It's a great word.
Yeah,
it's a good way.
It really is like a great,
first of all,
it's a word that you can get away with
no matter what.
It's not a word that you,
you know,
eventually you won't be able to use
anymore.
Oh fuck.
He is just going to be around forever
and it's just,
it is perfect for like nonsense.
Yeah.
I've,
I've been my English friends for years.
We're saying fuckery.
That's the thing that's in that it's
only recently catching on over here.
Yeah.
Really?
No last,
you know,
10 years.
I'm talking about since the eighties I
been here fuckery.
I'm trying to figure out when I started
using it,
I started using in regards to martial
arts,
like fake martial arts.
I use it in all kinds of stuff.
You can use it lightheartedly you could
use it seriously.
Yeah.
Everything.
It's as versatile as just plain old
fuck.
Yeah.
Steve Maxwell,
that's where I got it from and I started
using what Steve Maxwell,
he was describing some fake martial arts
talking about,
cause you know Steve's a black belt in
Jujitsu and he's like,
yeah,
it's,
it's a lot of fuckery.
And I was like,
Ooh,
it's a great word.
That's a word I'm going to keep using.
I just looked it up to see if there was
a good definition.
And it says it's also a definition for
another word for a brothel.
A fucker.
Fucker.
Right.
Holy Shit Dude.
You're just like opened my brain and a
new way.
Chorus.
Oh Duh.
Of course they'd call it,
are you going to the fuckery?
Yeah,
like a brewery of fuckery.
Oh that's too good.
Hilaire I never,
that never have dawned on me.
Had you not just vulgar slang.
Uncountable sexual intercourse.
What?
Yes.
Wow.
That which is fucked up.
That which is fucked up is
dow,
which is fucked up.
It's all the wrong Larry areas
definition.
It is a fuckery.
That is hilarious.
Okay.